ています
前にも1個くれいやいや者込みで我慢して
なジャンパー皆さんハンドスピナー
楽しいですねあ
うーん楽しいね実はにあると
平和給付ねなんかこうやって退屈しのぎになるんですよね待ってるだけで相手にする
だけでも随分遅いことは重要らもう分かっ理解したその上で言いますもっと別のトロス
見方があるんじゃねーかと思いましていけばしますよーいドン
これでだいたいどれくらいもあるたちというか見てみましょうはぁ
[音楽]
入り1分サンズ3秒ぐらいは改善しますはいて何で1分半ぐらいの回るってなかなか
ないと思うんだと思ったんですけど
国家実行バージョンは地面に置いてもう一個までおいて麻雀ってこれもう一個入って
マンダじゃんまずじゃん
辞令じゃねぇすごいよね命の輝きを感じるんですか
命に行け分派こういうふうに範囲でも改善住んでる奴を片方ていくと判断スピナーの頭
ができます
名付けてチャーリー
許嫁とや美男だけでハンガースピナータワー分かってる好きなんですけどもう花フェア
なぜ南ちゃうかというと放つあるかというと回転するからっても動きがずっと続いてる
からみんな興味を示してをちょっと見てるってそれをたくさん火山で行くともっといい
んじゃねーかな
姉御10個で満足するでしょう
で今回はこの回転しているハンドスピードを重ねていって&スペクターはなるべく高く
していこうと思います目標なんだから中はいけそうだ
gy てるだろ二重じゃないじゃあ21村なかったのに
20電波31個3充電ちゃんと改定している状態で30個重ねて30センチくらいの艦
娘の形を作り出して皆に感動してもらおうという
いい企画に企画純粋にねこれだと小学生も見てくれるかな
今俺の良いには線凝ったのピン流れからあーよく抜栓後記事から
そしては我々のもちろんスピナーを全部使ってやっていきましょー続きますさて
ええええええ
see
wh
ええええええ
[音楽]
うぇっうぇるこられん
サンダーつれぞ
ちょっとずれてる舐め morning run てると
もうやばいつエクエっなぁなは2日
タッチ位は言われ青がお顔が合えばへ
9ヒュー
なんでそんなに早いかああ
悪台ほど来た目高めのか誰も駄目だこの人だってなぁあとまであーこれもゲーム
オーバー集難しい見たときネイル結構異性というだけだはい
道
厚手分かった
となぜか売り出せるよね
ええええええ
するこういう
てつだっはい16
ee usare
ああああっ薄いてそっと一句が分かったのか
まず回転力が2ですよむ12番なぐらいと失速してくれるねーか難しいのと
無事にさよくなってくるとバランスが取りにくい胸が20万1分ん
頑張れば1ましょういきますよ
ん
[音楽]
特急ニュー
me
はいもう難しいよ本当に難しい打つべし
18おっはー
ずれたん
その派作家大外で上がるんだねっ
[音楽]
ハードタッチか per hour
goo
ni
me
teal
uh